racisme a décidé de porter plainte
contre Frédéric Augis le président de
Tours métropole pour un jour public à
caractère racial la conséquence des
propos que le maire de Joël est tenu à
l'encontre du maire de Fondettes en
traitant Cédric de Oliveira je cite de
salle portugais alors que risque-t-il
suite à cette plainte on fait le point
avec Faustine Luneau
jusqu'ici les réactions n'avaient été
que des condamnations verbales d'élus et
associations désormais l'affaire va être
présentée devant la justice après les
mots sale portugais qu'aurait adressé
frédéric-augis à Cédric de Oliveira le 4
avril dernier en marge d'un conseil
métropolitain SOS Racisme a décidé de
porter plainte pour injures publiques à
caractère racial contre le président de
la métropole devant le tribunal
judiciaire de Paris l'association dit
vouloir réagir puisque le préfet et le
parquet de Tours qui aurait pu s'auto
saisir ne l'ont pas fait qui que l'on
soit nous sommes tous égaux devant la
loi il n'y a pas de raison surtout
d'autant plus de surcoings
de tenir des propos comme ça comme je
vous l'ai dit dans notre espace public
si on laisse passer ça veut dire que
tout est égal en banalise et bien nous
nous n'acceptons pas ça en tant que
militant associatif c'est notre rôle
c'est de notre responsabilité de dire
que ces propos là et ben on doit les
condamner mais alors que risque Frédéric
oGIS le parquet devrait commencer par
diligenter une enquête pour caractériser
précisément les faits se posera la
question de savoir si c'est une injure
publique
ou peine en cour une ensole pas les
mêmes si l'injure est publique la peine
encourue la peine maximum et de 1 an de
prison et 45000 euros d'amende au
maximum et si l'injure est non public à
ce moment-là la peine maximum encourue
est une simple peine d'amande dont le
maximum est 1500 euros
l'affaire pourrait aussi être classée
sans suite au terme de l'enquête ou
tomber en prescription une fois le délai
d'un an dépassé d'autant que Cédric de
Oliveira n'a toujours pas porté plainte
contactez Frédéric oGIS n'a pas répondu
à nos sollicitations